Musik Wir machen jetzt hier seit neun Stunden, testen wir gerade, ob die Mikros funktionieren. Aber ich finde die Atmosphäre, was sagst du zur Atmosphäre, wir haben so einen lauen Sommerregen. Bis eben war sie gut, die Atmosphäre, in meinem Kopf. Und ich habe Gags parat gehabt, Sprüche auf Lager gehabt, habe mich hochgespielt ein bisschen und jetzt und dann testen wir acht Stunden die Mikrofone.
Warum ist die Tür so weit offen? Mach die Tür mal bitte zu.
Wow, ist die Klischee-Tür der Welt.
Hör nochmal.
Na, weil er jetzt ein Hörspiel produziert, wo viele knarchende, nirgendwo kommen so viele knarchchende Türen drin vor wie in Hörspielen. Wenn eine braucht, habt ihr sie jetzt auf Band. Wir hören Kohlensäure. Wir hören Florentin, der wieder ein bisschen dicker geworden ist, sitzt gerade vor mir, breitbeinig und hat sich gerade bekleckert, von oben bis unten.
Ein Bild für die Götter. Sie hören das Podcast-Ufo, Ausgabe 59. Wir garantieren Spaß, Spannung und Abenteuer. Mein Name ist Florentin, das Fun steht für Spaß. Wir sind jetzt hier und wir geben jetzt Gas. Nach mir am Mike ist der Stefan mit der geilen Show. Wir sind ein Podcast, das ist kein Radio. Mein Name ist Stefan, das Fun steht für Spaß, die Sonne scheint auf das grüne Gras, das Wetter ist heute nicht ganz so toll, aber ich bin zuversichtlich, das wird schon noch. Ich reime nicht mehr, warum auch? Ja. auf die Taler rasseln nur so hinein und mit mehr Erfahrung sind wir vielleicht auch so gut wie anderen Gäste, Liste, Geisterbahn, Radio Nukuladala oder dieser neue Podcast auf Spotify. Also oh. Beating of the heart echoes the beating of theft. Ich frage mich gerade Folgendes. Warum genau fandest du die Situation so unangenehm? Weil offensichtlich hat jemand dich erkannt aufgrund deines Podcasts, ich laufe daneben, aber sie wollte nur ein Foto mit dir machen, weil sie dachte, ja gut, den Freund von ihm lassen wir links stehen. Lassen wir, fügen wir dieses Grand-Puzzle der Awkwardness Stück für Stück zusammen. Du kannst nicht einfach Grand sagen und erhoffen, dass es irgendwie wertiger klingt. Auf jeden Fall wollte sie kein Foto machen, sondern so ein Video. Ich bin ein erfahrener Publicity-Typ, PR ist mein Leben, aber mit Videos bin ich noch selten konfrontiert worden. Ich kenne oft, dass man sagt, hey, hast du nicht Bock, ein Foto zu machen? Und was ich tatsächlich gemacht habe am Wochenende, was das Lustigste ist, was ich jemals gemacht habe, wo ich mich so stolz darauf finde, auf diesen Gag, ist da kam so ein Typ, schon ein bisschen betrunken auf mich zu und meinte, hey, du bist doch Florentin vom Medienmagazin, hey, wie geil hier, und ich hole mein Handy raus und sage, ja, willst du ein Foto? Ja, okay, klar. Und dann kommt der Typ, der neben mir stand, den ich kannte, hat einen Arm um ihn gelegt und ich habe ein Foto von dem beiden gemacht. Von dem Typen. Er ist mega verwirrt. Mega freundlich, mega lächelnd in die Kamera. Bis er merkt, Moment mal. Ja, kann ja, der hat eine E-Mail-Adresse haben, schick ihm das Bild, nur der ist nicht drauf. Das finde ich darauf achten, Leute sind wirklich in dem Moment, in dem ein Handy gezückt wird mit der Intention des Fotografierens, sind die paralysiert. Du könntest wirklich, wenn du zu einem Star gehst und sagst, hey, kann ich ein Foto haben und der macht nur ein Foto von dir, sobald er sein Handy rausführt, hörst du auf nachzudenken und du posierst nur noch. Also wie wir Mikrofone an sind oder Kameras an sind, du hörst auf nachzudenken, du bist so eine Stage-Persona. Ja.
Und das ist natürlich auch das Ding, wenn du einfach eine Kamera, wenn du weisst, irgendwas nimmt dich gerade auf, irgendwas nimmt gerade den Moment und verbreitet den irgendwie in die Zukunft, noch zehn Millionen Mal möglicherweise, dann bist du einfach anders. Die Leute wissen sehr gut damit umzugehen, fotografiert zu werden, weil man das häufig wird und die wissen, die sind einfach sofort im, oh Gott, ich muss gut aussehen Modus und schalten ihr Gehirn komplett aus. Ich habe, glaube ich, die Story schon mal erzählt, aber ist mir egal, dass ich beim Abiball meines vorherigen Jahrgangs Fotos machen sollte von den ganzen Pärchen. Und irgendwann hat es mich total gelangweilt und ich habe dann einfach angefangen, denen einfach komplett bescheuerte Anweisungen zu geben. Irgendwie, ja, nimm mal die Brille ab, ja, dreh dich mal um, nimm mal den einen Arm nach oben, komplett willkürliche Sachen. Dreh dich mal um, geh mal aus dem Bild kurz. Wirklich, so, das haben die alles gnadenlos gemacht.
Dreh dich mal um, mal eins von hinten, mal beide Arme in die Höhe, mal nur einen Arm in die Höhe bitte, setz mal die Brille von ihm auf, dreht euch mal um, die machen alles.
Schneid dir mal einen Arm ab, komplett einfach.
Ja, ich glaube wirklich, von der Hierarchie steht der Fotograf noch eins über dem Führer.
Was der Fotograf macht, machen die Leute.
Vielleicht hat der Führer ja auch irgendwann einfach hinter sich, was man jetzt nicht mehr sieht auf den alten Fotografien, einfach so eine grosse Kamera gehabt, einfach so eine grosse Kisscam einfach die ganze Zeit und alle hatten Angst halt, hoffentlich trifft es nicht mich und dann mache ich einfach, was der Fotograf sagt und eigentlich ist Hitler die ganze Zeit nur vor so einer großen Videowand, wo Leute Angst haben, in Sicherheit gezogen zu werden. Ich frag mich, ich meine, da gibt es wahnsinnig viele Sketche drüber und es wurde schon unglaublich oft bearbeitet, das Thema Zweiter Weltkrieg.
Aber ich finde es trotzdem immer noch lustig, diese Idee, dass so bitterböse Menschen wie Adolf hier, bitterböse, der bitterböse, steht so eigentlich auch im Wikipedia-Artikel, der bitterböse Detail. Der freche Haudegen, Adolfo, der Frechdachshimmler. Max Himmler. Ich finde aber, Adolf macht das auch ganz schwer, so tragend. Wenn er irgendwie Rudolfo hieß oder so, dann war so ein Name. Oder Mark. Ja, Marco oder einfach so Marvin. Einfach so ein Name, wo man denkt, ich kenne Marvins, manche sind nett von denen, aber Adolf ist halt wirklich auch so das Grundböse.
Aber ich frage mich da auch immer so, wie da so Marketing-Meetings ausgesehen haben, weil die haben grossen Marketing-Apparat.
Ich glaube, da gab es, ja.
Ich weiss, aber auch so mit dem Hitlergruss und mit den Totenköpfen auf den SS-Uniformen und so, dass man sich da wirklich zusammensetzt und Sachen macht und sagt, wie wär's.
Also was waren die verworfenen Ideen für einen Hitlergruss? Dass jemand irgendwie Thumbs up oder Peace-Zeichen oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, man sagt, nee. Oder auch fürs Hakenkreuz, auch die ersten Logos, was war davor? War irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, ja, oder ist Uber-Logo einfach eins zu eins. Man weiß es nicht genau. Oder so eine Biene. Aber es hätte auch sein können, dass irgendwann, möchtest du nochmal Biene sagen, einfach? Oder so eine Biene. Ich fand das echt lustig, die Vorstellung, dass so wirklich so ganz archaische, krude, kryptische Ruden und dann so eine fröhliche Biene. Wessen Idee war die Biene? Und ein so offensichtlich schwuler Nazi so. In so einer pinken Form, sorry, ich wollte ein bisschen Farbe reinbringen. Ein bisschen Farbe und ich meine, wir stechen ja andere Leute. Nein, tun wir nicht. Die Stechen-Idee haben wir auch verworfen, Maurizio. Es hätte ja durchaus sagen können, dass Hitler während seiner aktiven Zeit noch stirbt. Und dann hätten die Hitlergross, weil alle sagen, so brüsten wir halt unseren Führer, dann kommt der Nachfolger, zum. René Himmler. Ja.
Mann, der Name, der Name ist scheiße. Fuck you. Jede Annahme wäre besser gewesen, ausser Hitler. Der ist, was sprichwärts, wenn ich Müller einfach sagen könnte, es wäre besser gewesen als Himmler. Es hätte ja durchaus sein können, dass er wirklich stirbt. Und dann hätte man sagen können, oh, gut, René Müller ist jetzt der Nachfolger, gewählt vom Volk. Für Diktatur vielleicht nicht oder auch nicht. Je nachdem, wie sie Bock haben. Na ja, warum haben wir schon Bock auf Demokratie? Nee. Und dann sagen einfach alle Heil Müller oder Heil René. Wie sind wir eigentlich aufs Thema Diktatur und Hitler gekommen? Ach ja, unsere Fans haben uns angesprochen. Ach ja, Podcast-UFO, Folge 59. Wir wollten ein Video von uns machen, was schon mal unangenehm ist, weil wenn jemand ein Handy auf dich richtet, weißt du nie, wann wir jetzt wirklich gefilmt sind und wann nicht. Was auch echt eine Forderung ist. Ich finde es schon seltsam, ich finde es schon schwierig, einen Prominenten anzusprechen, können wir mal ein Foto machen und zu sagen, ich bin nicht drauf, ich will nur ein Video von dir, dann kann man die Kamera in die Fresse halten. Da gehört schon sehr viel dazu, auch was man von dir erwartet irgendwie so. Anscheinend hat man ein Bild von dir, dass du sehr nahbar bist. Ja, das ist auch komisch so, von wegen, ich bin kein Fan von dir, aber ich kenne jemanden, deswegen will ich einfach nur ein Foto von dir, ohne eine andere Person. Dann stehst du da wie der letzte Depp, weil normalerweise kannst du irgendwie den Fan in den Arm nehmen oder so, oder irgendwie gehst du da rumalbern und so, aber du stehst da einfach nur da auf dem Lidl-Parkplatz und denkst dir, wow. Exakt, Lidl-Parkplatz und dramaturgisch war auch wichtig zu erwähnen, dass ein Zaun. Also wir haben die Abkürzung genommen, wir gehen den Weg öfter, es geht quasi um so eine Ecke herum. Man kann diese Ecke abkürzen, diesen 90-Grad-Winkel, den man quer im 45-Grad-Winkel über den Lidl-Parkplatz läuft. So, rechts. Und dann, die sind aber den anderen Weg rumgegangen. Wir liefern die Gesten als Gif nach, keine Ahnung. Ja, ich mal es euch auch auf, irgendwie mit Paint. Und dann, und dann trennte uns ein Zaun, weswegen das auch so ein bisschen schwierig war, weil sie das Handy halt so durch den Zaun friemeln musste. Und man wusste, das war eine ganz interessante Situation, weil man nicht wusste, wer ausserhalb und wer innerhalb war. Es war einfach nur ein Zaun und das hierarchische Verhältnis, weil sie haben dann so gewunken, hey, Funti, dann bin ich zum Zaun gegangen, so wie so ein Affe im Gehege und nicht andersrum. Also diese Hierarchie war ganz fein definiert. Ich finde es übrigens, vor ein paar Wochen hatte ich so die Idee für eine ganz, ganz tiefgreifende, nachdenkliche Zeichnung von mir, wo ich mir dachte, sollte ich vielleicht das Metier wechseln in Richtung Philosophie eher.
Wo man hauptsächlich mit Zeichnungen arbeitet.
Und habe gedacht, man malt die Weltkugel und ein bisschen grösser da drauf ist ein grosses Gehege, man sieht einen grossen Zaun, da drin steht ein Tier. Und dann wird die Weltkugel immer kleiner, das Gehege bleibt aber gross. Und irgendwann ist das Gehege grösser als die Welt darum herum. Das heißt, wenn ein Mensch daneben steht, ist er irgendwann augenscheinlich im Gehege. Weil irgendwann, wenn das, ich meine, das meine ich auch oft. Was ist die Aussage davon? Wer beobachtet hier eigentlich wen? Das ist die Aussage. Aber ein Künstler sollte seine Werke nicht erklären. Na auf jeden Fall standen wir dann auf beiden Seiten dieses Zauns. Und ich wusste schon, dass die Situation kommen wird, dass es irgendwann heisst, ja okay, ciao, was geht, macht's gut. Und wir einfach beide in die gleiche Richtung laufen, nur der Zaun trennt uns noch und wir laufen einfach nebeneinander her. Bis der Zaun jedoch aufhört, wie in so einem Film. Und dann greifen wir uns einfach an. Genau, wie in so einem Film, wo man neben dem bellenden Hund langläuft und
irgendwie so Simpsons-Folge quasi.
Und den Hund auslacht, dass er eigentlich beißen kann. Genau, und dann
ist der Zaun plötzlich ein Loch und dann kommt er da raus.
Genau sowas auch. Dann hat der Zaun aufgehört und
bis dann einfach noch bestimmt Kilometer lang
in die gleiche Richtung gelaufen. Aber wir haben
sehr nette Leute, Conny und David
oder Daniel oder sowas, fantastisch,
tolle Leute, vielen Dank, die uns auch auf
Patreon unterstützen. Falls
ihr auch mal von uns öffentlich beleidigt und den Podcast
Vielen Dank. Tolle Gespräche geführt. Conny und David oder Daniel oder sowas, fantastisch, tolle Leute, vielen Dank, die uns auch auf Patreon unterstützen. Falls ihr auch mal von uns öffentlich beleidigt und im Podcast diffamiert werden wollt, dann einfach auf patreon.com slash daspodcast. Leider falsch geschrieben, vielen Dank an Stefan Titzer an der Stelle, das Podcast uft. Einfach da nochmal hinklicken und uns ein paar Dollar da lassen. Das finde ich auch übrigens immer lustig. Selten sieht man in Logos Schreibfehler. Ja, einfach so, wo man denkt, wo so viele Instanzen dazwischen sein müssen, dass da keine Rechtschreibfehler erlaubt sind, wie auf dem Shell-Logo, wenn einfach dann Shellp oder so steht. Wo man auch denkt, Leute, da hätte irgendwer, hätte es einem auffallen sollen. Aber die Welt schenkt, genau, vielleicht heißt es eigentlich Shelo.
Die konnten einfach nur nicht mehr zurückholen.
Shelk.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, die Welt hilft einem da auch nicht irgendwie.
Die gibt ja nicht mal einen Gag und dann steht da irgendwo mal Shelk oder so.
Nö, überall steht Shelk. Da muss man selber drauf kommen.
Wir haben ja angesprochen, letzte Woche waren wir in Amerika.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob du beobachtest an dir, dass du noch... Ich habe immer noch, ich kann immer noch nicht essen. Ja genau, wie du an dir beobachtest, dass du manche Behaviorismen übernimmst in den Alltag und du übernimmst in den Alltag. Und ich muss tatsächlich sagen, das einzige, was ich aus Amerika mitgenommen habe, waren ersten 16 Kilo Pfeffer mit M&Ms. Bei mir war es dieser große Finger, den ich bei Baseball hatte, mit dem ich jeden Tag rumlaufe. Das ist das einzige, was ich mitgenommen habe. Und alles wird automatisch interessant, wenn du es mit so einem Finger anschaust. Normalerweise stehst du auf einem Fisch onanierend und es ist irgendwie ein bisschen beklemmt, aber sobald du diesen Finger in der Hand hast, wird es zu einem zelebrativen Ereignis. Ja, alles, vor allem auch wenn du dann langweiligst, weil die meiste Zeit, muss man ja sagen, sitzt man beim Baseballspiel relativ gelangweilt, überlegt sich, was kann ich jetzt zu Essen holen gehen, das Spiel läuft einfach seit 18.000 Innings, du weisst nicht mehr, was Innings sind, und dann hast du halt diese grosse Hand und man sieht es ja eigentlich nur in Bildern, wo man dann die exzessiv hochhält und sagt, wow und schreit, aber die meiste Zeit sitzt man so ja nicht beim Baseballspiel, die meiste Zeit sitzt man so, dass sie einfach so locker an einem runterhängt, wie man halt sitzt normal oder so Arme verschränkt und es halt einfach so gelangweilt auch so, die ist ja auch nicht so ganz so fest, sondern dann hängt sie einfach so runter, so einfach so schlaff und dann sitzt man da einfach so und dann ist einfach so, ja. Und man zeigt auch nicht wohin, obwohl diese Geste halt so ausladen ist. Ja, genau. Ich finde es interessant, wie sich das entwickelt hat, dass dieser Finger sich als als Jubelgeste durchgesetzt hat. Niemand jubelt mit dem Finger! Das ist so geil, aber wenn ich noch eine grössere Hand hätte, wäre es noch viel geiler, der Finger. Ja dann ist irgendjemand auf die Idee gekommen. Wären wir bei Hitler. Diese Geste, die ich jetzt mache, mit dem grossen Schaumhandschuh, aber auch nur mit dem Zeigefinger. Aber das ist doch ein guter Zusatz für unseren Sketch, dass man auch den Hitlergruss durch so einen Schaumhandschuh verstärkt, der dann den Hitlergruss zeigt, so in Orang. Wusstest du, dass man stottert, weil man Angst hat davor, das Wort falsch auszusprechen und dadurch im Kopf überlegt, wie man das Wort umschreiben könnte oder sich Mühe gibt, es richtig auszusprechen und daran scheitert man, weil der Automatismus Sprechen wird dann einfach lahmgelegt und dann fängt es dann zu stottern. Das stimmt. Was mir auch auffällt, ist, dass manche Worte einfach nicht richtig aussprechbar sind, wie zum Beispiel Authentizität. Weil man immer, bei mir ist es so, das ist so ein klassischer Versprecher, dass ich immer schon, wenn ich merke, oh, in siebzehn Sätzen kommt das Wort Authentizität, dass ich dann immer schon denke, okay, gleich kommt's, gleich kommt's und es dann jedes Mal einfach verha hauen im Anlauf. Pfaffa, Pfaffa hauen. Bei mir ist es der Name tatsächlich. Also Leute denken, ich heißt Steffa Pfaffa an. Ist nicht so guter Gag. Freundsche Versprecher, ist das für dich ein Thema? Freud hatte ja vor ein paar Wochen Geburtstag, nochmal alles Gute zum Geburtstag, schick deine Mutter, Alles Gute zum Geburtstag, Pervision ist vielleicht normal, alles Gute, Sigmund Freund, alles Gute lieber Sigmund, du bist doch auch schon völlig gestört. Hoch soll der Leben, hoch soll der Leben, fahr los! hatten kein Geld mehr und ich wollte nachfragen, ob man den Cash bezahlen kann. Und dann habe ich gefragt, can we pay in crash? Ich habe crash gesagt, can we pay in crash? Und da dachte ich mir, okay, das ist doch so ein... Sofort Handbremse gezogen, crash, what the fuck? What the fuck, did you study psychology? Because that was a pretty textbook example of a slip of the tongue. Und dann wolltest du sagen, freudschapersprecher, aber du kattest, glaube ich, den Term nicht richtig, ne? Slip of the tongue, sagt man. Aber da kommt das Wort Freud, aber nicht für den freudennamen. Das ist ein Sternchen, man macht dann immer so mit der Hand so ein Sternchen auch in die Luft. Aber ein klassisches Beispiel für einen freudscher Versprecher kann man es natürlich psychoanalytisch analysieren, von wegen ich hatte Angst davor, dass wir einen Unfall bauen oder ich wollte unterbewusst, dass wir einen Unfall bauen, damit ich endlich die geilige Geschichte zu erzählen zu können. Genau, oder dich loszuwerden, um endlich aus dieser libidinösen Zweierbeziehung rauszumachen. Die Chance, dass ich sterbe bei einem Unfall und du nicht, ist relativ gering. Nein, nee, du hast recht, du saßt auf der linken Seite und links hinten ist man am sichersten, weil der Fahrer in einer Unfallsituation reflexartig seine Seite des Autos schützt und somit bist du links hinten, bist du sicherer und der rechts vorne hat komplett verloren erstmal mal. Also die Kinder auf dem Kindersitz komplett, die sind so gut wie Tor, kannst du das Grab schon mal schaufeln und rechts hinten hast du eigentlich auch verloren. Den Kindersack schon mal schreien anlassen. Ich finde auch, man sollte immer einen Kindersack schreien. Bereit auch in seiner Wohnung einfach bereit halten. Man weiss nie. Wo ich nochmal zu Diskussionen kommen wollte, ich habe dir geraten zu einem Koffer, wo wir gerade in Wohnung aufbewahren waren, weil du denn nicht, du wolltest dir keinen Koffer kaufen, weil du nicht in der Wohnung lagern wolltest, weil du sagst, nimm Platz weg. Meine Argumentation war, in dem Koffer ist aber nichts drin, der verdrängt nicht viel Luft, du kannst ihn befüllen mit Dingen. Aber gerade weil nichts drin ist, nimmt er so viel Platz weg. Ich weiss nicht, warum du dieses Konzept nicht verstehst. Aber demnach kannst du auch keinen Schrank in dein Zimmer stellen, weil er so viel Platz wegnimmt, weil da nichts drin ist. Aber da sind ja Sachen drin. In den Koffer kannst du auch Dinge reinmachen. Was tust du denn, wenn du nicht im Urlaub bist, in deinen scheiss Koffer? Zum Beispiel den grossen Handschuh, den du aus deiner USA-Reise mitgebracht hast. Den habe ich immer an. Zum Beispiel den grossen Baseballschläger, den du dir gekauft hast, weil du ein scheiß Fehlkaufproblem hast, in dem Euroshop. Dann zum Beispiel den grossen Football, der mittlerweile kaputt ist und auch schon weg wahrscheinlich. Und auf dem Dach liegt. Und auf dem Dach liegt leider. Dann die Scherben deiner Jimmy Fallon-Mug, die du gekauft hast, die der Zoll leider zerbrochen hat, leider. Dann deine Plasmakugel, die du im Natural History Museum gekauft hast. Einfach mal rein. Warte, ganz kurz. 15 M&M-Packungen, die du gekauft hast, die sofort zerbrochen hat, leider, dann deine Plasmakugel, die du im Natural History Museum gekauft hast, einfach mal rein, dann die 15 M&M-Packungen, die du gekauft hast, im M&M-Store, kannst du rein, ich wüsste ein paar Dinge. Das war echt, also Stefan ist ja manchmal echt ein unsympathisches Arschloch, aber es gibt so Momente, da muss man ihn einfach lieb haben, und für mich eine Situation, wo ich mir achte, einfach, ach Stefan, war in Amerika, in New York, am Zoll, bei der Kurzunter-Sicherheitskontrolle und Stefan völlig panisch, oh scheiße, ey, ich habe so eine Plasmakugel dabei, ey fuck, was ist ein Plasma, ist das Strom, ist das gefährlich, kann man damit ein Flugzeug lahmlegen, diese scheiss Drecksplasmakugeln, die du irgendwie bei zwei Watt an Stecker ansteckst und dann sind da so in so einem scheiss Gasvakuum so Drecksteile dabei. Und Stefan dachte allen erstens wie so eine Plasmagranate, die der mächtigste Gegenstand des Universums. Ich finde, Plasma klingt schon sehr gefährlich. So, dann da habe ich im Hinterkopf die ganze Zeit gehabt, dass ich mir extra eine Zahnpasta Tübe gekauft habe, weil man die grosse nicht mitnehmen kann im Handgepäck. Ich hätte aber jetzt eine fucking Plasmakugel im Handgepäck, die irgendwie auch einen Liter drin fassen könnte, Flüssigkeit theoretisch. Ich natürlich keine Ahnung, Physikgrundkurs, keine Ahnung, was Plasma ist. Bezweifel auch stark, dass da Plasma drin ist. Ja, aber es heisst halt Plasmankugel und ich hatte echt panische Angst, dass sie mir die einfach wegnehmen. Haben sie nicht gemacht, es war ein Vatertagsgeschenk, muss man dazu sagen. Die Geschichte geht noch viel weiter. Natürlich war es kein Problem, ich konnte die mitnehmen. Ich habe mich übrigens, was man auch machen muss auf jeden Fall, wenn du zur Sicherheitskontrolle gehst und was abgibst zu deinem Koffer, dann direkt die Ohren zuhalten einfach und diese stabile Seitenlage legen direkt schon. Gag lacht! Den Gag haben wir importiert aus den USA, zollfrei. Ich finde es auch schön, für was für Vollidioten du deinen Vater halten musst, dass er wirklich begeistert ist von so einer scheiss Plasma-Elektriker. Ich wusste nicht genau, was ist Plasma, jedenfalls fass man das an und dann kommen so Stromsachen. Da dachte ich mir, okay, entweder das oder den Dinosaurier-Code, den man kaufen kann nebenan, habe ich mich dafür entschieden. Und ein Problem ist leider, ich habe das dann zu Hause gebracht, alles gut zum Vatertag, cool, passt mal cool. Und dann ist leider passiert, du hast ja in den USA andere Anschlüsse für Steckdosen. Du hast einmal 230 Volt und einmal 130 oder so, keine Ahnung. Und jedenfalls verträgt das nicht deutsche Steckdosen einfach. Also er hat es angeschlossen, es ist instant kaputt gegangen. Es ist instant, es fing an zu stinken, das Netzteil hat angefangen zu qualmen, eine Plasmakugel war im Arsch, das war der beste Vatertag. Happy Birthday to you! Es war echt der beste Vatertag seines Lebens, glaube ich, einfach. Und er hat nur ein Kind, er hat nur ein Kind, es hat eine Chance, einen Vatertag gut zu machen, steckt eine Plasmakugugel, ist schon scheisse, glaube ich, das Gefühl, mein Sohn schenkt mir eine Plasmakugel, er hat mich völlig aufgegeben anscheinend, macht es rein, direkt kaputt.
Wir waren, wo du dieses Plasmacool gekauft hast, im Museum of Natural History in New York und da bin ich direkt zu den Kröten gegangen, zu den Fröschen und Kröten, weil ich die sehr spannend und sehr ekelhaft finde und da habe ich tatsächlich, also das das habe ich bis heute noch nicht ganz verarbeitet, was ich da gesehen habe. Und zwar, es gibt so Frösche, so ganz platt gedrückte schwarze Frösche, die hauptsächlich auf Autobahnen leben, an den Rändern von Autobahnen. Ne, war ein kleiner Bugs unter uns. Hui, heute haben wir so eine ganz andere Humorfarbe, so eine nicht funktionierende einfach wahrscheinlich. Schlechte, schlechte Humorfarbe. Es gibt so schwarze, plattgedrückte Frösche, die heißen irgendwie Piu-Piu oder Plu-Pla oder Plupp oder irgendwie so Kram. Ich glaube, Piu-Piu. Plattgedrückt, weil es ein Gag, weil die schon totgefahren sind, oder? Das war die erste Finte, jetzt rede ich ernst. Mein Gott, und die sind halt, die haben halt die Beine eher so nach außen anstatt nach unten. Weiß ich so wie, ist das ein Gag, keine fucking Ahnung.
Nein, das ist kein Gag.
Und das Geile an denen ist, dass die wirklich in ihrem Körper Löcher haben.
Die haben in ihrem Rücken...
Ist das jetzt...
Sorry, du bist in so einer Humorspirale gefangen.
Nein, es ist einfach kein Gag, ist es nicht.
Ich bin einfach...
Nein, mach nicht den Olympischen Fehler.
Und täglich grünt der Plattfrosch, grüßt der Plattfrosch, weil ich habe keine Ahnung,
ist es jetzt ein Gag, bin ich noch in einer Gag-Spirale, ist es noch Humor, du hast jetzt Löcher innen drin, ich kann dir nicht glauben auf diesem Weg. Der Schweizer Frosch, nein, ich meine es wirklich ernst, ich meine es wirklich ernst, es gibt Frösche, die haben wirklich in ihrem Rücken einfach Löcher, wo, und dann ejakulieren die irgendeinen Scheissschle! Und so ein Kram ist kein Witz. Das ist die unnahbarste Geschichte. Und dann, hör mal auf jetzt! Deswegen erzähl ich, weil es so abgefahren ist. Die haben wirklich so Löcher und Kuh in ihrem Rücken, so Wuppel. Also ekelhaft, mega ekelhaft, wie so ein Puzzle, wo man so Klötze reinstecken muss. Und dann kommt die Frau und sagt, what up, hebt ihren Rock, spritzt da irgendwie so einen Schleimscheiss raus. Er spritzt da auch seinen Schleimscheiss raus und dann läuft ihm das so über den Rücken, so nach dem klassischen Doggy-Style, läuft dem Typen das so über eine... Froggy-Style. Oh, Jackpot! Und dann läuft ihm das so über den Rücken und dann bleibt diese ganze Suppe in diesen Löchern in seinem Rücken hängen und dann entwickeln sich wirklich in seinem Rücken die kleinen Babyfrösche. In seinem Rücken oder in ihrem Rücken? In ihrem Rücken, mein Gott. Und dann bleiben die da hängen und dann entwickeln sich wirklich wie so ein Schulbus. Einfach hat dieser Frost schon so ganz viele kleine Frösche in seinem Rücken wirklich und dann irgendwann sagen die, tschau, mach's gut und hauen ab und sind da raus. Wie lange leben die denn da? Also wie Kängurus, relativ lang oder? Ich weiss nicht, eine Woche vielleicht einfach so und die chillen da einfach. Ach so, die gründen dann auch da irgendwie so eine kleine Stadt auf dem Rücken, so eine kleine Kolonie. Ich glaube, die spielen viel Karten oder so, weil die halt so ein Stück auseinander sitzen. Es spielt so ein kleiner Seven Eleven und dann wird so ein kleiner Subway noch gebaut und dann haben die ihre eigene Stadt. Ja genau, irgendwann verlassen die halt ihre Mutter dann und dann ziehen die in ihre eigene Welt. Aber Kängurus sind ein tolles Thema. Wusstest du, dass der Kängurubeutel sehr schleimig ist innen, dass er so nah, dass er, ich glaube, so nahhafter, das ist eher wie so ein Jacuzzi.
Ja, also sehr eklig, so ein bisschen in die Fruchtblase noch, ne, quasi.
Ist auch ein Scheisskonzept, Känguru, vor allem was machst du, wenn das Kind nicht ausziehen will.
Ja, aber auch hier die Evolutionsfrage, Theorie.
Die Evolutionsrubrik, Teil 27. Verinnert sich, während wir singen. Wappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappappapp auch cool. Und dann unser Folgendes, also das Konzept Beutel ist ja jetzt schon mal nicht so, Beutlin ist ja jetzt schon mal nicht so toll. Warum sterben die nicht aus? Weil, oder warum haben es, wenn es so eine tolle Idee ist, Natur, wow, gute Idee, warum haben es dann nicht auch andere Tiere, zum Beispiel Fledermäuse oder Kängurus? Oder warum hat nicht einfach jedes Wesen einfach so eine schöne Bauchtasche, wo sie einfach so ein bisschen so Kleingeld reintun können oder so gefangenen Knochen oder so ein Kram. Ist eine gute Frage, ist Känguru tatsächlich eines der wenigen Wesen, das sich nicht rückwärts bewegen kann. Das heißt, wenn sich das mal irgendwie dumm einmanövriert in so einem Parkplatz. Wie Aale tatsächlich, deswegen gibt es Aale-Reusen. Richtig, es gibt so eine Nationalhymnene von irgend so einem Land, ich glaube Australien oder so, und da werden zwei Tiere erwähnt, deren Eigenschaft es ist, dass sie nicht sich rückwärts bewegen können. Da habe ich dann, das hast du mir schon mal erzählt, daraufhin habe ich dann gesagt, wow, einfach die Hymne fing an so, Australien, du bist die tolle Landschaft, wir lieben dich, wir sind stolz auf unsere Freiheit und wusstest du, dass es Tiere gibt, die nicht rückwärts laufen können? Ganz abgefahrene Geschichte, hat meine Oma von erzählt, aber gar kein Problem. Jetzt kommt die zweite Strophe. Australien, da in der Wissen frei und Demokratie und aber es gibt auch so eine Federmausart, die hat eine ganz irre Eigenschaft und Leute, glaubt es nicht. Falls ihr nicht wisst, was sich in Kängurubeuteln befasst, dann schaut mal in Staufe 7 nach, da könnt ihr vielleicht was indenken. Ohne zu viel Wache anzuholen. Ist aber interessant, aber Nationalhymnen sind ja ein interessantes Thema, glaubst du? Nee, erzähl mal zu Ende die Geschichte. Ähm, ja, die sind, die werden als Sinnbild für Australien, das hast du mir ja... Das mache ich aber jetzt immer. Einfach um, erzähl doch mal diese Plasmakugelgeschichte weiter, mal gucken, was noch kommt. Die werden als Sinnbild für das australische Volk benutzt, weil sie sich nicht nach hinten bewegen können, sondern immer nur nach vorne oder stehen oder schlafen oder damit beschäftigt sein, ihren scheiß pubertären Kängurus. Oder einfach immer auf der Stelle bleiben. Einfach auch nicht so schön, Australien. Ist auch nicht so schön. Was seit Jahren in den 80er Jahren, keine Ahnung. Was hat Australien hier erreicht? Keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung. Bestimmt viel, man kriegt es halt noch nicht mit, weil die alles auf ihrer Insel da haben. Auch nicht so schlecht. Wir haben in dem Museum auch einen grossen Blechglobus gesehen. Sei nicht wir, du bist da allein rumgelaufen. Nein, den haben wir zusammen gesehen. Hast du jemand gesagt, Stefan, auf mit dem herzulaufen, geh jetzt mal einfach die Dinosaurier angucken, ich komme dann gleich wieder, hol dich bei den Dinosauriern ab, guck dir den jetzt mal an.
Stefan stand die ganze Zeit mit gekreuzten Armen und mit seinem Künstlerblick vor den Kuscheltieren im Shop und ich sage,
nein, Stefan, die echten Dinosaurier sind da draußen, da ist ein riesiges Museum. Und Stefan, nee, nee, ich will noch kurz zu den Smarties, ich will mir die Smarties noch kurz angucken.
Stefan war komplett daneben in dem Museum.
Ich war ein bisschen eher daneben, wir haben ja vorher so einen Corndog gegessen, das bekam in ... Corndog, oh Corndog, they are so good to me. Corndog, oh Corndogs, they are so good to me. They're good when they hold, they're good when they're fresh. They're good ... Nein, nein, nein. Nochmal? Good when they're hot, they're good when they're cold, good when they're fresh, good when they're old. Was nicht stimmt. Sie sind weder, ich habe ja mit diesem Lied in den Flieger gestiegen, zum Corndog-Stand gerannt und gemerkt, es ist weder geil, wenn es kalt ist, noch wenn es nicht frisch ist. Und man muss sagen, Corndog ist einfach eine Beefy-Roll. Wir Deutschen haben da einfach ein anderes Wort dafür. Eine abgelaufene Bifirol. Sollte auch bei Dict-CC eigentlich stehen. Abgelaufene Bifirol, Corndog. Ich fand, bei dem Corndog hat sich auch das erste Mal gezeigt, dass einer unserer Kollegen, ich sag jetzt nicht seinen Namen, unterbewusst schwellig rassistisch ist. Max, Patrick, Max. Weil wir haben diesen Corndog bestellt und wir haben schon den ganzen Flug dahin gesagt, wir kaufen uns Corndogs und haben uns dann Corndogs gekauft und dann hat er gefragt, ja, Senf oder Ketchup? Und dann habe ich einfach gesagt, ja, so wie man die normal isst, so wie sie ein New Yorker essen würde und dann hat er gesagt, ja, just like that. Und dann haben wir die einfach so genommen und dann hat ein besagter Kollege, er hat dann gesagt so, ja, der hat bestimmt gesagt, dass man die so isst, damit er sich Senf spart. Und ich dachte, what? Man muss dazu sagen, die beiden Verkäufer waren schwarz und da war für mich angeklungen, so geht's nicht, mein Freund, dass du denen sofort einen jüdischen Ehrgeiz unterstellst, Geld zu sparen, nur weil die schwarz sind. Du hast ein bisschen, wo wir gerade bei dieser Rassismus-Ecke sind, du hast ein bisschen Shitstorm bekommen für deinen antisemitischen Gag. Also man würde sagen, irgendwann die grossen Antisemiten, Hitler, Himmli, Dieter Nuhe, Florentin Will, weil du hast einen Gag gemacht bei Twitter zum Eurovision Song Contest, wo ich mir auch frage, also es sind ein paar Fragen aufgeklappt in meinem, ey, ich kann es nicht mehr hören. Aber warum warst du die ganze, nee, nee, nee, wenn du einmal das Wort Uralgebirge sagst, verlasse ich deinen Raum. Ich meine, das ist wirklich ernst. Nee, ich würde nur gerne fragen, warum du da warst. Ich war nicht vor Ort, tatsächlich, wie es viele internationale Beobachter auch schon festgestellt haben. Ich habe die Schlagzeilen gesehen, Leute. Du wurdest fotografiert vor Ort. Ihr müsst mir keine Links mehr schicken, ich weiss, was die Presse um mich schreibt. Ich war nicht vor Ort. Ich habe es tatsächlich gesehen über ein Fernsehgerät. Ich bin gerade so wussig, wie der Satz, wenn das Wort Uralgebier gefällt, wie ich hier raus für Aussenstehende wirken mag. Hm, was ging da vor vorher? Nein, ich habe einen Gag gemacht, und zwar Deutschland hat Israel zwölf Punkte gegeben, und ich habe geschrieben, ja, Deutschland gibt Israel zwölf Punkte, jetzt sind wir quitt. So, und dann ist er recht gut angekommen, aber es haben auch viele Leute sich beschwert, von wegen, er hat geschrieben, ich kann es nicht mehr genau, aber irgendwie, wenn verschiedene Länder gegeneinander antreten, das Grauen ist immer mit dabei. Die Widerlichkeit war es, glaube ich. Die Widerlichkeit, genau, die Widerlichkeit ist immer mit dabei, das fand ich schon ganz schön. Ich wurde schon als vieles bezeichnet, aber die Widerlichkeit, da ist Stefan, oh nein, die Widerlichkeit ist auch dabei. Ich wollte schon so einen flippigen Kommentar schreiben, so, oh, die Widerlichkeit, kann ich das für mein Tinder-Profil haben? Aber dann dachte ich mir, nee, ist noch beschissener eigentlich, mach ich nicht. Weiss ich nicht. Also ich meine, es ist ein ernstes Thema, weil es ist natürlich wieder so eine Humordiskussion, was darf Comedy und was nicht, aber für mich ist immer so der Punkt, wenn ein Mensch denkt, dass folgende Aussage richtig ist, wer über einen Witz über Thema X lacht, der lacht über Thema X. Wer denkt, dass diese Aussage richtig ist, da kann ich einfach nicht mehr helfen. So, das ist einfach falsch. Wir sind ja in einem sehr ernsten Metier. Ich kann nur sagen, es ist, wenn man über Humor spricht, so als würde man auf dem Rücken eines Frosches Kinderzeugen. Ja, ich wollte ein bisschen auf den Anfang der Folge zurückkommen. Nee, aber es ist wirklich so, also das ist mir was, was mir häufiger auffällt. Der sagt so, oh, man macht einen Witz über Vergewaltigung, jemand lacht drüber und Leute nehmen das so wahr, als würde man über Vergewaltigung lachen. Und das ist schlicht nicht wahr, weil die gesamte Idee eines Witzes ist, dass man eine Distanz herstellt. Man nimmt sich Elemente aus Serialität, nimmt die raus, führt sie auf eine Distanz und baut daraus einen Witz, über den man lachen kann. Die gesamte Idee des Konzeptes Humor und Witz ist es, dass eine Distanz herrscht, dass es nicht um das eigentliche Thema geht. Und dann kommen wir wieder so Sachen, dann machst du einen Hitler-Gag und dann schreiben Leute, Hitler hat so und so viele Leute vergast und hier und da. Das ist ja das Problem, als würden sie denken, man würde nicht wissen, was Hitler falsch gemacht hat, aber dabei macht man den Gag ja gerade, weil man weiss, dass es so furchtbar ist, was Hitler gemacht hat. Also das kann ich immer nicht verstehen. Hör auf, mich an den Kragen zu fassen, die ganze Zeit auch mich gegen die Wand hier zu drücken. Ja, es ist aber mal ein Thema, das gesagt werden muss. Setz dich mal wieder hin jetzt. Es ist einfach was, da haben viele Leute einfach noch keine Ahnung. Na ja, gut, du hast das Thema angefangen, du musst ja nicht über Holocaust reden. Nee, nee. Und dann, Leute, da sieht man auch schon oft, Leute, die Scheisse schreiben, an Punkt Y in ihrem Satz, tun das oft schon auch an einem anderen Punkt. Man sieht oft schon, dass Leute auf einer falschen Bahn ... In der Twitter-Biografie zum Beispiel. Zum Beispiel. Oder alle, die sich beschwert haben, haben nicht das Wort Holocaust benutzt, sondern das Wort Schoah. Also das jüdische Begriff für Holocaust oder grosser Schlamassel. In einem Wort implizit. Grosse Scheisse. Grosser. Grosse, grosse Kacke. Uiuiui. Das lief nicht gut. Nicht unsere beste Zeit. Sechs Millionen zu drei vielleicht. Aber auch so ein Wort zu benutzen, wo man irgendwie ausdrücken will, man hat sich schon ein bisschen länger damit beschäftigt. Genau. So dieses, ja, man darf nicht die Sprache der Sieger der Geschichte benutzen, sondern die Opfer müssen auch gehört werden. Und man benutzt das Wort der Opfer der Geschichte, der Holocaust ja schon ein bla bla bla. so ein ganzer Kram. Da ist, da ist viele kluge Gedanken dahinter. Man sind auch nicht Juden, man sagt Jüdinnen oder so eine scheisse Gender-Kacke da, Inuit und so ein Kram. Inuit und so ein Kram. Inuit und so ein Kram. Und da darf man, also da ist natürlich viel kluge Theorie dahinten und das ist alles nicht per se lächerlich, aber es ist schon so ein gewisser Sprech, wo man schon merkt, okay, da sind vielleicht auch andere Gedanken dahinter, als dass es wirklich ums Thema geht, so dass man sich vielleicht auch auf eine gewisse Art präsentieren möchte. Du hast eine grenzpolitische Erfahrung gemacht, ich war im Kino und es ist folgendes passiert. Ich bin in einen relativ langweiligen Film gegangen, von dem ich wusste, eigentlich sollte das ziemlich gut werden, habe ich gehört, ich weiß auch im Nachhinein nicht, wer mir das gesagt hat. Captain America Civil War, der neue grosse Marvel-Film. Das ist die Filmkritik, Rubrik. Das ist die Filmkritik, Rubrik. Können wir machen, meinetwegen.
Es wird nicht die ganze zu. Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da da daHits. Ich bin in den Saal gekommen und dann standen da, waren da so ganz speziell, eine Reihe war ganz speziell, es war eine ganz spezielle Sitze und da habe ich vorher mal die Radiowerbung über dieses Kino gehört, wo diese Sitze beschrieben wurden, so ein Radiobeitrag und zwar sind das die Motion oder die Box Seats, die heissen die glaube ich, so ganz abgefahrene Sitze, die mit dem Film mitgehen und so einen Scheiss,
also wie diese Simulatoren, die man auf Jahrmärkten hat. Und ich dachte mir, okay, wenn ich irgendwann mal in einem Kino so eine Scheisse mache, dann doch in diesem Film, der mit Sicherheit nicht so geil wird, wie die Leute mir gesagt haben. Also bin ich ins Kino gegangen, Oh Mann, Fickau Stefan!
Hab, nee, warte ab!
Und dann habe ich mir tatsächlich noch für diesen Platz gesichert in einem dieser Sitze
und es war unfassbar geil einfach. Du kannst dann einstellen, die Stärke, mit denen du im Film mitgeschleudert wirst. Und es ist einfach so, es ist einfach, also ich sage euch Leute, Stufe vier ist was für die Harten unter euch, ganz im Ernst. Von zwanzig. am Anfang von Captain America ist dann so eine direkte
Kampfszene, weil es einfach die ganze Zeit Action, was einen ein bisschen wahnsinnig macht. Ich dachte mir, komm, ich gehe all in, Stufe vier und wurde dann in der ersten Szene direkt so einfach nach vorne geworfen. Popcorn war weg einfach, aber es war einfach grossartig, weil du hast es nicht genau im Blick, du hast es auch noch nie, das ist so eine ganz seltsame Situation, in der du dich gerade befindest, einfach. So, du kannst ein bisschen überleben mit diesem Sitz und du bist im Kino, wo du die ganze Zeit einfach nur normalerweise sitzt und versuchst, irgendwie bequem zu sitzen. Keine Chance einfach. Und ich dachte mir, er kann sich einfach ein bisschen nach vorne bewegen, ein bisschen zurück bewegen. Nein, er kann auch wirklich sich doch links und rechts und der Rasse einfach komplett aus. sich überschlagen sind. Und was wirklich lustig wird dann irgendwann, ist der Gedanke daran, wenn du dir jemanden dir vorstellst in einem Ding, dann hast du so eine 3D-Bild im Kopf, aufgerissen, Mund, yeah, geil, aber so guckst du keinen Film. Die meiste Zeit guckt man einfach nur mit seinem Popcorn und seinen Nachos und der Cola in der Hand, guckt man so relativ gelangweilt und lockerlässig den Film, aber du wirst ja die ganze Zeit rumgerissen, rumgeschüttelt und so. Und das ist einfach eine wirklich lustige Situation. Was auch dazu führt, wenn du halt am Anfang, der Film hat irgendwie so ganz viele Spielorte, dann ist er in Bulgarien und Berlin und so ein Scheiß. Und dann kommt am Anfang halt immer der typische Establisher über die Stadt, das heißt so ein Helikopter schwebt über die Stadt und dann wird der Name eingeblendet oben, irgendwie, ja, wir sind nicht Berlin, Germany und so ein Scheiß. Und dann dachte ich mir, okay, geil, wenn er sich nur auf die Action-Szene konzentriert.
Aber nein, auch solche, einfach so einen Schwenk macht er halt mit,
indem er einfach von unten links nach oben rechts geht.
Einfach so Szenen, wo man denkt, gib uns mal kurz einfach einen Moment.
Dann schwenkt er einen so mit einfach. Das ist ja echt geil.
Das ist ja echt. Ich stelle mir das Kino vor,
wenn wirklich 300 Leute komplett entspannt und ruhig da sitzen.
Nur Stefan, wow, wow, krass, überall fliegt Popcorn rum. Die ganze Reihe war frei, nur ich sass in dieser bescheuerten Demo-Box-Seed. Natürlich. Und es war wirklich lustig einfach. Aber bewegen sich die Schüler auch, wenn man niemand drauf sitzt? Mega unangenehm. Ne, wenn niemand drauf sitzt, nein. Okay. Die werden dann aktiviert erst. Ich bin erst, ich habe natürlich erst... Du warst alleine im Kino? Ne, mit dem Kumpel tatsächlich, der war auch.
Der sass in der letzten Reihe.
Hat sich irgendwann den Raum verlassen.
Hatte keine Lust darauf.
Ne, und ich dachte erst, gut, ich hol mir einfach für die Loge Tickets und geh dann
runter zu den Dingern und lass mich dann da drauf und dann werd ich da rumgeworfen.
Ne, ging aber nicht, weil du musst die erst aktivieren, du musst erst bezahlen für die
Sitzung und dann werden die aktiviert. Moment, das heisst, du bist dann nochmal rausgegangen und hast dir noch eine Karte gekauft? Ne, ich habe die upgradet. Was ist denn die Loge im Kino? Oben, Parkett und Loge. Ein zweistöckiger Kino? Nö, einfach der letzte Teil des Saals. Ich weiss auch nicht, warum man das Loge nennt, das ist eigentlich ein falscher Gebrauch des Wortes. Mezzanine heisst das eigentlich. Ne, ne, das ist oben, das ist die zweite Etage. Du bist komplett woanders. Sandwich nennt man das, glaube ich. Photosynthese, glaube ich. Heute Morgen haben wir beide in der Hashtag-Konferenz den exakt gleichen Gag gemacht. Das war echt ein Moment. Was man nicht aussprechen kann. Was man schlecht schreiben kann. Was man schlecht schreiben kann, wo man nicht weiss, wie geschrieben wird. Wir haben beide gleichzeitig Rhythmus gesangt. Ja. Einfach so, aber komplett gleichzeitig so. Wir werden einfach zu, wir morphen zu einer Person. Es ist wirklich gruselig. Ich glaube aber, dass wir mittlerweile, dass wir das gar nicht gleichzeitig sagen, sondern wenn der andere nur Luft holt und so der erste Laut nur rauskommt, wir sofort verarbeiten und grossen Reflexe haben und einfach das gleiche hinterherhauen.
Das ist ja so gut darin geworden, die Pointen des anderen so ein paar Sekunden nachzuschieben. Nach der Stream. Und deswegen können wir uns so gut synchronisieren. Sichchen. Aber er ist ja eben so krass. Es ist unglaublich. Es ist mir krass, es ist mir krass. Es ist mir krass, es ist mir krass. Das ist kein Ding heftig.
Comedy, wir machen was mit Spass und Freude und Lachen, Lachgarantie. Das ist gar nicht heftig.
Comedy, wir machen was mit Spaß und Freude und Lachen, Lachgarantie. Hab ich nie gesagt. So, ich greife jetzt mal zu. Weißt du was, letzte Woche haben wir zum ersten Mal, glaube ich, in der Geschichte des Pufos, sagt niemals Pufo einfach, haben wir zum ersten Mal nicht geschnitten, gar nicht. Also wir haben nicht mal, gar nicht, wir haben nicht mal eine Szene rausgenommen, nicht mal ein kleines bisschen.
Und ich fand es mega angenehm, weil ich musste dann halt einfach nicht eine Stunde da sitzen und an Erfolge rumdoktern und in die Worte verschieben, damit es irgendein Gag raus wird und so einen Scheiss. Und das fand ich echt angenehm, deswegen sollten wir das eigentlich jetzt immer machen. Aber dann habt ihr auch mal so Situationen wie jetzt, wo wir einfach dann so ein bisschen Luft holen mal zwischendurch und mal überlegen, gut, wo kann es gleich humortechnisch hingehen. Aber da müsst ihr dann durch. Was habe ich noch hier, Kinositze, abgehakt. Wir wollten über Angst sprechen eigentlich heute, ne? Wir wollten das grosse Thema Angst machen. Jetzt reden wir schon sehr lange über andere Dinge.
Ich finde, Angst schwebt immer so als Unterthema mit eigentlich.
Was sagen Sie gleich? Kommen Sie wieder mit der Scheren-Story? Diese Angst, die man als Hörer hat? Nein, ich rede nicht mehr davon. Macht die Scheren-Bewegung. Nee, wir wollten eigentlich über Angst sprechen, weil ich einen Artikel heute gefunden habe, den ich noch nicht gelesen habe, weil ich dachte, das machen wir einfach, diese Experience erleben wir einfach zusammen.
Wow, die Erstlesung dieses fantastischen Artikels. Dieses Abenteuer eines Artikels erleben wir zusammen. Der Artikel 150 Dinge, also nehmt euch in Acht, diese Folge dauert noch 18 Stunden. 150 Dinge, vor denen die schlauesten Menschen der Welt Angst haben. Und das finde ich wirklich interessant. Aber das ist ja tatsächlich mein Lieblings-Loriot-Sketch, ist ja der Sketch, wo er bei dieser Lesung und dann dieser Dichter seine Sachen vorliest und er sagt dann, ja, ich lese heute 38 Gedichte, vier Aphorismen und halt so wahnsinnig viele einfach die Forschung, 38 Gedichte nacheinander zu hören. Und diese Bewegung, die durch den Raum geht, wenn man sagt, ja, ich lese heute Abend 38 Gedichte und alle so, oh nein, 38. Oh nö. Oh Gott. Ich finde auch eine konkrete Zahl zu wissen vorher. Will man nicht hören. Will man nicht. Wenn man genau weiss, um jetzt oben nach oben zu gelangen, musst du in diesem Gebäude 138 Treppenstufen gehen. Das willst du nicht hören. Ja, doch was angenehhmes, so wie dieses Eis besteht aus 87 leckeren Schläckbewegungen. Das will man nicht hören, das ist einfach zu rational, man kann es ja nicht mehr geniessen. Ja, aber auch in New York, wo überall zuerst, grösser noch als der Preis, die Kalorien geschrieben waren. Ja, das war ganz unangenehm. Will man auch nicht hören. Wo Stefan mal versucht hat, die Kalorien zu zahlen. Ja, grosser Erfolg, das waren meine grossen Momente, wie ich mir beim Labello auf Preise einfach auf Produkte gezeigt habe. Hey, gib mir einfach mal einen Smoothie. Redberry Smoothie. Och Mann, ich bin so ein uncooler Typ. Warte, war einfach. Redberry. Scheiss, Alter. Redberry ist okay. Warum laufe ich nicht mit einem Bier durch die Gegend und einmal mit der Zigarette nuckele ich dabei?
Warum sage ich Wörter wie Nuckeln? Ich bin der uncoolste Typ der Welt einfach.
Warum machst du mich nicht mal ein bisschen cooler? Sorry für die Frage.
Ja, hau mal raus. Also, 470 Ängste von den erfolgreichsten Menschen der Welt.
Wir haben einen sehr lustigen.
Ich würde sagen, hau erstmal die ersten 306 raus und dann gucken wir weiter, wie es funktioniert.
Wir gucken mal, wie es ankommt an der Reaktion der Leute. Hier ist einer sehr lustig. Nicht so viel, ich fahre Motorrad ohne Helm. Jay Craig Venter, Genomwissenschaftler. Wow, ich weiß nicht mehr, was ein Genom ist. Wie ein Gen. Gen. Nee, wie das Gen. Ja, sowas Ähnliches, glaube ich. Das schneide ich raus. Dass wir aufhören werden zu sterben. Wow. Hm, interessant. Eine Welt, in der man nicht stirbt. Ja, forever young, forever young, I want to be, I don't want to be forever young. Hey, Macarena. Und wollen wir in einer solchen Welt leben? Ich glaube nicht.
Männer. Helen Fisher, Biologie-Anthropologin.
Männer sind ihre grösste Angst?
Die tiefgreifende Arroganz der Menschheit, dass Technologie die Demokratie bedroht,
gegenseitige Zerstörung. Okay, hier haben wir ein bisschen monothematisch sind wir hier.
Sind das gute Themen für einen geckigen Schlamassel-Podcast, wie wir es sind? Dass wir uns zu viele Sorgen machen, stark miteinander Pärchenbildung. Das ist eine Gefahr, Pärchenbildung. Ich glaube, das war einfach so ein Opfer, der keine Frau abbekommt, der einfach dachte, in diesem Artikel zeige ich es denen. Ja, der gesehen hat, es gibt sieben Milliarden achtund siebenundzwanz, einunddreissig Menschen auf der Welt. Das ist eine ungerade Zahl. Wenn jetzt alle Pärchen haben, muss einer übrig bleiben. Wahrscheinlich ich. Ich war vor ein paar Tagen echt sauer und war kurz davor, Apple zu schreiben. Hatte ich dir schon mal erzählt, und zwar die Kopfhörer, die man in dem Film hört, die sind einfach, das ist das Perf perfekteste, was ich mir vorstellen kann, dass du morgens zwei Wireless-Kopfhörer in deinen Kopf steckst, der einfach, der dir sagt, schönen guten Morgen, was soll ich sagen, wie das Wetter wird, was soll ich sagen, was soll ich machen, was soll ich sagen, ich bin total nervöser, was soll ich sagen, ich habe auch nicht gut geschlafen und ich habe nichts vorbereitet, ich sage es nicht. Du hast mich nicht so richtig aufgeladen, ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich sagen soll. Blackout einfach. Tu einfach was, wer fängt an, wer sagt zuerst was. Das passiert mir nie. Und dann, dass man sagt, ja, wie wird das Wetter heute, dann sagt es einem das. Ich habe keinen nicht in blassen Schimmer. Was soll ich anziehen, sagt mir, was ich anziehen soll. Ja, zieht doch einfach die Übergangswerke an. War heute, willst genau zwölf Grad? Ab 16 Grad trägt man kurze Hosen und solche Regeln einfach, an die man sich halten kann. Aber irgendwann, nachdem du das einen Monat benutzt, merkst du, dass es gar keine Computerstimme ist. So einfach Florentin, den ich verarscht. Oder einfach so ein Typ in Indien, der irgendwie am Telefon sitzt und dich dann irgendwie durch Masturbationen erzählt hat. Ja, also Siri kann ja auch schon viele Fragen beantworten. Wenn du einfach zwei Bluetooth-Kopfhörer in deinen Ohren stecken hast, die... Warum willst du mal zwei haben? Das verstehe ich. Stereo-Sound. Du hörst doch auch mit zwei Ohren. Dann hörst du den ganzen Tag nicht. Da haben sich die Natur zwei Ohren gegeben. Ja, damit du ein Kopfhörer tragen kannst und ansonsten noch die Ampel hupen hörst. Ja, du kannst aber Transparency-Mode anmachen, dass du sie hörst. Ich hab mir schon die Modes überlegt. Die Kopfhörer gleichzeitig aufnehmen und das dann einspielen in dein Ohr, was sie aufnehmen. Ja, wie ein Hörgerät. Ah, so funktioniert also ein Hörgerät. Ein Hörgerät, verstehst du, wegen dem Film Hör? Wow, geil! Ne, es gibt auch mittlerweile jetzt so Kopfhörer, die simultan übersetzen, was der andere gegenüber dir sagt. Die können bislang aber nur Italienisch, Französisch und Englisch. Das heißt, wenn beide ein Kopfballer im Ohr haben, können die miteinander sprechen, obwohl die nicht gleich Sprache sprechen. Aber das klappt doch nicht. Doch, es gibt ein Video davon. Es klappt doch nicht mal, dass Siri hier einmal Spandau versteht und die sagt, wo wir uns die Spaghetti bestellen. Das kann doch nicht funktionieren, dass jemand mir gegenüber irgendwas erzählt und es funktioniert. Ja, wenn es übersetzt wie Bing auf Twitter, dann glaube ich, hat man massive, dann könnte der Dritte Weltkrieg nämlich austreten, wenn irgendwie Putin mit Merkel spricht und sie sagt, ja, in dem Aussi-Deutsch, ja, wie geht's dir? Oh Gott, oh Christi, ja, servus. Ja, wenn die denn sagt, mit ihrer typischen Angela Merkel-Stimme, ja, ja, wie geht's Ihnen? Hallo, hallo, ich bin anglischer Merkel. Hallo, hallo, wie geht's Ihnen, warum sind Sie denn schon so früh da? Und dann sagt Putin dann zurück, irgendwie sowas wie, weil er hört, wir wollen, wir wollen, wir wollen mit Ihnen Krieg führen. Auf Deutsch hat es, ach ja, ist funktioniert. Ja, ihr könnt euch den Bitschern vorstellen. Ihr könnt den Gag ja denken. And then, it's wrong, because Bing is used to it.
And then, the third world war on a dumb mistake and blah, blah, blah, blah.
Do you know what Trump is doing? impressions since i was in new york and then there was like people in the subway were listening to me were doing my donald j trump impression and they were just taking with their heads and just saying shut the up you german idiot but i'm still j j trump so who are they talking to I mean, I'm not a German idiot, my ancestors were German. So, halt die ganze Zeit.
Ja, ich verstehe das. So, die ganze Zeit. Du kannst nicht für 20 Sekunden Bit machen und dann fragen, wäre das nicht eine lustige Idee, eine komplett schlechte Imitation machen, so funktioniert es nicht. So funktioniert Comedy nicht, meinst du? Ne. Ja. Ne, was ich aber übernommen habe aus Amerika, wo wir gerade bei Amerika waren, ist dieser Entschuldigungswahn. Ich bin immer noch in dem Modus, dass ich mich für jeden Scheiss entschuldige. Ja. Und mittlerweile nimmt das absurde Züge an, weil Entschuldigung ist ja eigentlich scheisse. Entschuldigung ist ja, wirft man ja der Entschuldigung immer so vor, dass man sagt, man entschuldigt sich, anstatt was zu tun, dass man einfach sagt, ah, das ist mich betrogen, ja Entschuldigung, anstatt dass man irgendwie dann was macht, um es besser zu machen. Und das kenne ich sehr gut. Und heute habe ich mir, hatten wir eine schöne Mittagspause, gab es einen schönen Hahn, ja, und da habe ich mir schön Hahn auf meinen Teller gewuchtet, einfach drei, vier Hähne. Wie man in Köln sagt, Hahn. Na, und dann ist ein Stück auf dem Boden gefallen, und da habe ich zu sehen, wie ein Stück auf dem Boden gefallen, habe ich nur gesagt, oh, Entschuldigung, und bin gegangen. Und bin einfach mit dem Raum verlassen. Und dann stehe ich draußen und denke mir, Moment mal, was war das denn gerade? War das eine crazy Situation. Oh, sorry, macht nichts und geht einfach so. Bei dem Stück hast du dich entschuldigt. Ich beim Boden, glaube ich, habe mich beim Boden instinktiv und bin gegangen, habe sie nicht aufgenommen. Ich glaube, das nimmt ganz absurde Züge an, durch dieses Konstante Entschuldigen. Ich entschuldige mich auch aber auf Englisch die ganze Zeit noch, wenn ich so durch die U-Bahn laufe. Excuse me. Sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry. Was mache ich? Wollte ich auch heute kurz sagen, ich habe heute zum ersten Mal seit langem wieder Kontaktlinsen drin und keine Brille auf. Und daraufhin kam heute unsere Kostümdame dann zu mir und hat gesagt, wow, die sieht so viel besser aus ohne Brille mit Kontaktlinsen. Und ich auch denke, fuck you, ich trage seit zwei Jahren jetzt diese scheiss Brille. Mir jetzt zu sagen, dass ich ohne Brille besser aussehe, ist der falsche Zeitpunkt. Ich habe es schon verbessert an mir. Und nicht Dinge sagen, nachdem man sich schon verbessert hat. Das ist der falsche Zeitpunkt, wenn man sich falsch macht, weist mich darauf hin, dass ich gerade Senf am Mund habe. Ich bin auch zu den Maskendamen gegangen, es waren zwei Maskendame, und eine hatte plötzlich kurze Haare, die trägt normalerweise lange Haare und hat jetzt kurze Haare, wir haben uns lange nicht gesehen. und sie hat mich so angeguckt, so ah, new me. Und ich auch so, ah, kurze Haare, okay, cool, ah, ist ein Pferdeschwanz. Und da kurze Haare hat sie sich umgedreht und ah, okay, kurze Haare, ja, steht hier, ist schön. Und sie hat nur so, nee, ist eine Perücke. Die Perücke hat genommen, hat immer noch lange Haare. Und da kam ich mir auch schon ein bisschen dumm vor, ehrlich gesagt. Das ist das Problem, du erkennst schon etwas, aber da haben sie sich nur verarscht. Das ist so next level Sexism. Ja, vor allem, ich weiss nicht, dann dachten sie eigentlich, dass das Kompliment vielleicht ironisch war, weil man mit einer Perücke nicht so gut aussieht. Aber ich meine, die sind auf der anderen Seite professionelle Maskenbilder, die wissen, wie man Perücken baut. Kannst du Komplimente machen? Überhaupt nicht. Ich auch nicht. Gar nicht. Es ist immer nur so eine Mischung, ich mache glaube ich Komplimente wie so ein 68-Jähriger her, so sehr so, oh, sieht doch aus, als hättest du gestern das Abi gemacht. Ja, mein Problem ist ein bisschen, dass ich mir manchmal zu gut merken kann, welche Komplimente ich Menschen schon gegeben habe und ich ihnen dann eigentlich nicht nochmal sage, so dass ich, wenn ich einmal sagen kann, hey, du bist echt lustig, nie wieder erwähnen werde, dass die Person lustig war, ich einfach irgendwie weiss das schon. Oder wenn ich irgendjemandem sage, aber alle Menschen habenes Gedächtnis. Ja, tatsächlich, und man will ja auch Komplimente häufiger hören, also nicht aus narzisstischer, Menschen sind scheisse Art, sondern es ist ja auch ein gutes Gefühl, man will häufiger, man will besserfalls jeden Tag hören, dass man gut aussieht und viel oder viel ist. Fällt mir gar nicht ein. Aber ich denke mir immer so, auch habe ich eigentlich schon gesagt so. Hast du zu mir schon mal gesagt, dass ich lustig bin? Nein. War noch nie vonnöten. Mittlerweile regnet es draußen gegen das Fenster, wo wir die ganze Zeit melancholisch rausschauen. Ich würde ganz gern die Atmosphäre reinlassen. Och ne, komm. Und tatsächlich habe ich ein cooles, ernst gemeintes neues Feature, das ich entdeckt habe. Und zwar ist es ja immer das Problem, wo findet man neue Musik. Und Spotify hat jetzt ein neues Feature, dass sie dir auch bei selbst, haben sie wahrscheinlich schon ewig und ich habe es ja selbst bemerkt, dass sie bei selbst angelegten Playlists immer darunter deine neue Kategorie eröffnen, so basierend auf dieser Playlist neue Sachen. Und das ist mega gut, weil du ja schon so meine absoluten Lieblingssongs, so die besten Songs ever in einer Playlist und die finden und sie sind echt gut, du findest dann echt gute neue Songs, die da auch ungefähr reinpassen. Echt jetzt? Bei mir ist, ichhm, ich benutze immer dieses Hits der Woche, ähm, basierend auf meinem Geschmack. Stephans Mix der Woche. Alter, was habe ich für einen scheiß Geschmack. Ja, denke ich mir auch immer so, was muss Spotify von mir denken, so man schämt sich auch dafür. Nur Musical-Songs, sehr viel Stravinsky und sowas. Ja, und eben, was jetzt bei mir auch kam, irgendwie, dass sie mir so vorschlagen, so Regensachen, so Regenatmosphäre und so, weil ich habe tatsächlich auch eine Playlist nur mit Regen und die haben mir auch vorgeschlagen, so der neuste Scheiss auf dem Regenmarkt, so, Alter, das musst du hören, ey, Regen an Fenster 28, richtig geiler Scheiss. Was wird denn irgendwie in Folge 39 noch neu gemacht? Wir haben jetzt noch krasseren Regen, Tsunami, irgendwann wird es auch krass, wir haben jetzt nur schreiende Leute eigentlich, fliehende schreiende Leute. Und ich denke mir auch sofort, Alter, in zwei Wochen kommt das neue Album raus, ey, Rain Nummer 68, Alter, ich freue mich so, das wird so krass. Die grössten Rain-Hits. Ich weiß, sie haben sich irgendwie jetzt neu ausgerichtet. Ultimative Schadshow, die grössten Rain-Hits. Ja, es gibt viele Live-Sachen sind drauf, aber auch ein paar Studio-Versionen, ein paar Instrumental und solche Sachen. Habe ich lange an einem Tweet gearbeitet, ob man da was machen kann, irgendwie der neueste Scheiss oder so, aber mir ist es eingefallen. Ja, aber Spotify ist ganz interessant. Ich habe da auch hingeschrieben, weil ich diese Idee gut fand. Keine Hobbys, kein Privatleben, Stefan! Schreibt Mails an Unternehmen, um sie zu nerven. Und dann haben die diese Community, wo man halt Ideen reinschreiben kann. Und dann werden die in der Community halt diskutiert und dann dann kommen Moderatoren, und die besten Ideen werden halt an Spotify herangetragen. Geiles Prinzip eigentlich. Und da habe ich halt vorgeschlagen, dass man hört, was Leute gerade in deiner Umgebung hören. Und dann kannst du quasi mit Leuten connecten, die in deiner Umgebung sind in der Mittelbahn, und du siehst quasi, okay, das Mädchenform in der U-Bahn hört gerade Musik, vielleicht Spotify, vielleicht hat sie das Feature aktiviert. Ja kannst dann einfach mega creepy sagen, ja, Avril Lavigne finde ich auch gut.
Woher weißt du das so?
Nee, sie muss es ja auch eingestellt haben.
Der ist aber trotzdem ein bisschen creepy.
Ich finde es aber ganz schön geil, dass du halt einfach hörst, was gerade Leute in der Umgebung hören
und dann im Idealfall, wenn in welchen Geschmack habt, dann irgendwie so eine Chatfunktion entsteht,
wo man dann schreiben kann oder so.
Finde ich ganz geil, weil jeder hört noch für sich selber Musik.
Warum nicht mehr das teilen? Ich will sehen, wenn der Typ in der U-Bahn tanzt, wozu der gerade tanzt. Und das ist ganz cool, glaube ich. Warum er keine Hose anhat. Und dann habe ich das vorgeschlagen und dann haben die gesagt, ja, ihr Thema wurde schon 80 Mal vorgeschlagen, wir haben das Seil einfach gelöscht. Das war leider der Outcome dessen. Keine Liebe für Stefan Tietze, keine Möglichkeit, Leute, kennen Sie. Aber Anerkennung. Schlagt mal bitte vor, dass Sie in der Mobile-Variante auch den Text einblenden lassen können. In der Desktop-Variante kannst du den Text, Lidtext von Songs einzeigen. Oh, kann man jetzt tatsächlich? Wirklich? Und zwar vom neuen, warte mal, können wir hier eigentlich Musik jetzt abspielen im Hintergrund? Nee, da fragen wir nicht. Doch klar. Weil man kann jetzt, der neue Justin Timberlake-Hit zum Beispiel, muss ich mich kurz outen, ist ganz geil, finde ich ganz cool. Habe ich noch nicht gehört. Der hat auch beim Eurovision Song Contest dann diese Halftime-Show gemacht. Da war ich nicht da. Was aber tatsächlich ganz krass war, weil der halt als Ami einfach komplett Europa gezeigt hat, wie man richtig Musik macht. Zum einen richtig Show macht, zum zweiten. Und einfach, dass diese geile Bühne im Hintergrund nicht nur als Projektionsfläche für so dumme kitschige Wölfe oder Pflanzen und so dienen, sondern einfach auch ganz cool aussehen können. Was meine Theorie auch ist, je schwächer die Demokratie in einem Land, desto kitschiger und trashiger ist die Performance beim Eurovision Song. Auf jeden Fall. Ich glaube, man kann auch die politische Zukunft eines Landes abhängig machen an der Performance. Weissrussland, die krasseste Diktatur in Europa, hat dieses Jahr den Vogel abgeschossen, hat einfach so einen Wolf animiert, der die ganze Zeit herumgelaufen ist. Das hässlichste, kitschigste der Welt. Aber wie fandest du als Humorexperte die komödiantische Einlage im ESC, diesen Song, der sozusagen den klischeehaften ESC-Gewinner-Song auf die Schippe genommen hat? Hast du den gesehen? Nee. So dieses Love, Love, Peace, Peace. Ach so, ja. Fand ich echt lustig, hat mir gut gefallen. Also war ein guter Einwurf. Ja, ich finde es auch generell ganz lustig dieses Jahr eigentlich. Ja? Also die Show war halt, ganz im Ernst, es ist eine coole Veranstaltung, da bleibe ich dabei. Also aus Showperspektive, weil es einfach eine wahnsinnig grosse, teure Veranstaltung ist, die sind in den meisten Teilen geil, weil die einfach nur zu dem Zweck da sind, dich zu unterhalten. Aber es tut halt kein Land was dafür, ausser das Gastgeberland, was dafür zu tun. Und es hat schon so ein bisschen so ein Zusammengehörigkeitsgefühl von Europa irgendwie. Das finde ich schon ganz gut. Dann schaut man in die ganzen Hauptstädte rein und sowas. Du kannst jetzt hier Behind the Lyrics machen. So. Massive Gamer-Probleme momentan. Ja. Aber ich habe mir überlegt, wie wäre es denn eigentlich meine neue idee mein grosser pitch esc nur nicht popmusik sondern comedy ich will mal so ein belarus-typen auf so einen schönen auf weiss russisch 60 minütigen rant über die verhältnisse in belarus hören so kennt ihr das wenn ihr frühstücken wollt dann kommt ein Bär durch die Tür und ich sag, Leute, ich hab keinen Honig mehr. Was bei uns ja auch in Amerika, wir waren in manchen Shows, ein bisschen problematisch war, weil wir waren oft die Mehrheit im Publikum. Und wenn die Mehrheit Deutsche ist, ist es natürlich schon ein Problem für die Talkshow-Hosts. Generell für eine Humorshow. Aber es ist auch ein Problem, wenn die halt dann irgendwie die so innenpolitische Sachen besprechen und die Mehrheit des Publikums einfach nicht lacht, aber die andere Hälfte dafür umso stärker als Amerikaner sind. Das fällt schon auf. Auf jeden Fall. Würdest du dich bereit erklären, Deutschland zu vertreten beim ESC, ES Comedy? Heisst auch ESC, das ist problematisch. Eurovision Song Comedy. Sins Super Comedy heisst das dann. Äh, ja. Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Aber wahrscheinlich würde mich der NDR dann nominieren und dann würden Leute sagen,
nee, der hat schon mal antisemitische Tweets geschrieben und so und dann würde ich sagen, den können wir nicht aufstellen. Kennt man. Alles klar. Wir freuen uns auf nächstes Jahr. Erstmal auf nächste Woche. Auf nächste Woche, wenn es wieder heisst das podcast ufo wir hören das podcast ufo woche für woche und es wird
einfach nicht besser bis zum nächsten mal haut rein macht's gut. Wir sagen Tschüss, das war Stefan und Florian.
Bis nächste Woche. Ciao, wie bei bei. Tschüss, wir heben ab.